uh this is also a good place to give a
shout out to a video titled the entire
soviet rocket engine family tree by tim
dodd aka everyday astronaut it's like an
hour and a half it gives a full history
of soviet rockets
and people should definitely go check on
support tim in general that guy is super
excited about the future super excited
about space flight every time i see
anything by him i just have a stupid
smile on my face because he's so excited
about stuff
yeah i love people like
great if you're interested in anything
to do with space um he's in terms of uh
explaining
rocket technology to your average person
he's awesome the best i'd say
you